we're a Banana Republic
I don't we're a Banana Republic without
the bananas
I know we've seemed increasingly like a
Banana Republic in recent years we have
now become one
there has been all sort of sort of saber
rattling in recent years about how we
need to lock up our political opponents
in fact it was one of the most popular
lines of Trump's 2016 race lock her up
lock her up great line during the debate
Hillary Clinton said I don't want to
live in Donald Trump's America Trump
said yeah because you'd be in jail
they got lots of Cheers but he didn't
actually do it
because
conservatives said
we don't actually want to live in a
country where we arrest the political
opposition we don't actually want to do
that it's a good line and especially
when it comes to someone like the
clintons they have committed lots of
crimes but we're just going to err on
the side of caution here that is not a
good look that is what tin pot
dictatorships do
so what do the libs do
they indict Trump
that's Crossing the Rubicon
especially because Trump is not just a
former president
he is the current chief rival to Joe
Biden
he is the current leader of the
political opposition
and our liberal ruling class is now
arresting the leader of the political
opposition
because we are not a nation of laws
we are a nation ruled by the Caprices of
men specifically of liberal men
when a mob comes into the Tennessee
State Capitol and disrupts the
legislative session and walks on the
floor of the capital and says no action
no peace which is a direct threat of
violence following a leftist terror
attack in that very City just days
before
coming up on this is the day before a
planned day of Vengeance also by
leftists that's fine that's a peaceful
protest that's applauded the White House
applauds that that kind of action and
stands with the transgender community
and that's all wonderful the real
victims you know
but when some Midwestern grannies show
up and get a police guided tour of the
capital in Washington D.C that's an
Insurrection that's the worst coup
d'etat ever in the history of the world
they've got to go sit in solitary
confinement
because our liberal ruling regime
arrests political dissidents
and now arrests the leader of the
opposition
can you believe can you
can you believe that Vladimir Putin
has arrested and jailed his primary
political opposition in Russia
yeah I can believe that
I can
I see that thing happen all the time
not just in Russia and China I see that
here too it's exactly exactly what the
leftists
are doing really sad for the country
some of us thought the country was
already pretty far gone
that this is simply the The Logical Next
Step the illogical next step of that but
it is good news for the Trump campaign
the story is about Trump
the Liberals fear Trump rightly or
wrongly maybe you would say well some
other candidate would make a better
president he would do more conservative
things maybe
but it's about Trump
that's what it's about he's offering a
genuinely different vision
than has been offered by Democrats or
Republicans at any point in our entire
lifetimes
at least in my lifetime some of you
might be a little older than I am lady
never tells but
he's the guy
it's about him he's already got a big
lead in the race I suspect it's going to
increase his popularity now the question
is
will it help him to win those early
primary States if he's wearing an orange
jumpsuit he's not going to be able to
campaign in Iowa New Hampshire
crucially he's probably going to have a
harder time raising money the Grassroots
will still give him more donations but
he's going to have a hard time raising
money from the big donors who don't want
to sink their money into someone who is
potentially going to end up in prison
so it'll it'll hurt his campaign in that
regard
and the Liberals are doing this to
prevent him from becoming president
again there's another investigation into
him in Georgia they're going to try to
throw him in jail in Georgia too
also on bogus charges
though not quite as absurd as the
charges in New York they're arresting
the man
for don't allegedly donating money to
his own political campaign and not
filing the correct paperwork
seven years ago
it's complete whatever charges Putin
makes up to arrest his political
opposition whatever charge is Xi Jinping
opposition
those charges are no more absurd than
the charges the Liberals are making up
in America to arrest the political
opposition here
we are the libs wanted to get rid of
American exceptionalism
they did it congratulations Libs and
that's something and you remember that
radical transgender group that responded
to the shooting in Nashville by mourning
the death of the shooter
and insinuating that the real victims of
the shooting were the transgender
identifying people well that's pretty
much the White House position too one of
the things that we saw during the
midterm elections is that people don't
want their freedoms to be taken they
want us to fight for their freedoms and
so it is shameful it is disturbing and
our hearts go out to uh those the trans
Community as they are under attack right
now
the trans Community that's what's up our
hearts go out to the trans Community
under attack after a
transgender attack on little kids at a
Christian School where we still haven't
seen the manifesto but what the chief of
police suggested was that gender
ideology played a pretty big role in the
attack
the real victims the real victims the
real victims
the trans Community it's a bit that Norm
Macdonald did Norm Macdonald did a
comedy bit
that is now
commentary from the White House
spokesman Norms bit pertained to the
real victims
of the last wave of Acts of terrorism
I can't say my friend's name but he said
his biggest fear
is
that Isis or some terrorist group like
that would get a hold of a dirty bomb
and exploded over a major city within
the United States
and kill
tens of millions of people
because then
the blowback against
innocent Muslims would be absolutely
terrible
yes that's right that's true okay let's
do some jokes
that's true yeah of course
that's true yeah we agree they don't
know how to respond to Norm
the real tragedy would be the blowback
against the peaceful
Muslim the real tragedy here
of course is that some people now might
not like transgenderism as much or might
not think it's true
the radicals always have to be the
victim
they always have to be the victim
the radicals
are radical ruling class and whichever
group of people is being used as a tool
of that radical ruling class they have
to be the victim
they could be attacking you they could
be committing an act of murder they
still have to be the victim it is not
possible for disfavored groups in
America ever to be the victim
Christians conservatives white people
men at least men who know that they're
men
those people can never ever be the
victims if they are attacked they had to
have brought it on themselves
if they are attacked the real tragedy is
going to be the blowback the blowback
that never seems to happen by the way
but the blow but the hypothetical
blowback against whichever group
perform the attack it that that is not
the conclusion of our ruling class that
is the premise
we've all seen it happen before I'm not
going to go through the rigmarole of can
you imagine if the shoe were on the
other foot imagine if the rules were
reversed I'm not gonna I'm I can't do it
I can't do it I can't bring myself to do
that because that is going to be the
Epitaph on the gravestone of
conservatism
but we see it constantly and we see it
here most clearly there there will never
be an incident it doesn't matter how
extremely gruesome morally clear that
that incident is there will never be one
for which the ruling class
says that a disfavored group is actually
the victim we've got more to get to we
got the written mailbag questions the
old school written mailbag questions and
then we've got fake headline Friday fake
headline Friday is where I need your
help except
I do not see
my iPad so I'm going to blame producer
Jacob for that but it's all happening
now so make sure you go to dailywire.com
subscribe enter code Knowles now it's
daily wire.com Knowles I don't know
there's all sorts of slashes and codes
go to dailywire.com Knowles use code
nulls at checkout for two months free on
all annual plans
[Music]
foreign